immer und ich habe ein zitat mitgebracht
von benjamin franklin ich habe das ist
eben auch schon mal irgendwie so bekannt
nämlich diejenigen die ihre
grundlegenden freiheiten ausleben würden
um ein wenig vorübergehen
sicherheiten zu erlangen verdienen weder
freiheit noch sicher halten und er am
anfang der krise wurden ja viele
grundlegende freiheiten eingeschränkt
habe also bis heute auch nach wie vor
eingeschränkt zu recht am anfang aber
seitdem ist notwendig war sind jetzt
schon über anderthalb jahre vergangen
fast 2 und wenn sich der kontext eines
muss eine entscheidung richtig war nicht
richtig bleiben und es ist so als würde
man in der flut ist vollkommen richtig
in rettungsboote zu haben aber wenn die
elbe dann da ist es fast schon absurd in
einem rettungsboot sitzen zu bleiben und
mittlerweile treffen sich geimpfte
erhalten anderthalb meter abstand haben
tragen masken und fast nur noch das
infizierte kugelschreiber an und ich
will auch gar nicht beurteilen ob ich
das richtig und ob das richtig ist oder
nicht ich kann es auch gar nicht
beurteilen aber
was ich ganz neue fragen will ist wann
kommt eine handschlag zurück und wann
kann ich wieder spontan ins museum gehen
ohne dass ich drei tage vorher einen
termin vereinbaren muss ohne dass ich
beim einlass beweisen muss mit einem
zertifikat dass ich gesund bin das
betrifft ja dann auch irgendeine corona
und ohne was ich mach's getragen muss
das ist kein freedom day gibt es okay
gut gibt es jetzt hier nicht aber gibt
es wenigstens in frieden ja also kommt
dieses jahr wo wir über freiheit
sprechen können wo wir wissen können
dass unter gewissen voraussetzungen all
diese einschränkungen die wir vor
anderthalb oder vor über anderthalb
jahren jetzt erfahren haben darauf
aufgelöst werden und über diese
voraussetzungen wird sehr sehr wenig
gesprochen und bei dieser frage
interpretieren ja auch schon sehr viele
menschen geglaubt sie gar nicht angucken
und das ist auch schon das ding es ist
alles geht hier gleich um glaube und das
ist auch mein zweites thema nehme ich
die meinungsfreiheit die ich dann auch
in freundeskreisen schon mit erlebe dass
wenn man über verschiedene themen
spricht und verschiedene meinungen hat
dass man sich in so einem umfeld begibt
wo man das gefühl hat vielleicht könnte
die bombe platzen die auch so eine
freundschaft zerreißen kann und es wird
ganz ganz oft unterteilt in für oder
gegen für flüchtlinge gegen flüchtlinge
für
klimakrise gegen klimakrise für gruner
maßnahmen gegen korona maßen links oder
rechts und meine antwort darauf ist
weder noch es ist nämlich so komplex ich
wünsche mir einfach nur dass ich das der
handschlag zurück kommt und dass ich
ganz normal mit meinem freund menschen
argumente austauschen kann dann fangen
wir mal an
das war ein tolles kino je für die
freiheit glaube ich
habe ich mich total am herzen ich weiß
nicht ob sie heute ein interview oder
das interview mit dem ehemaligen
verfassungsgerichtspräsidenten
hans-jürgen papier gelesen haben in der
welt bei den kollegen der welt muss man
sagen ein wirklich tolles interview und
da hat der ehemalige
verfassungsgerichtspräsident doch
deutlich und muss man sagen extrem
scharf abgerechnet mit dem was in der
korona pandemie falsch gelaufen ist
gerade in bezug auf die grundrechte und
auch die einschränkungen der grundrechte
und hat aufgefordert hat gesagt
das muss jetzt ganz ganz dringend sowohl
von parlamenten also von politikern wie
auch von gerichten aufgeklärt werden
denn das was da passiert es war zum teil
absolut irrational war absurd wie ja
auch gesagt hat also eine kleine
abrechnung eines top juristen und der
genau das beklagt hat dass in der
pandemie sukzessive immer stärker der
staat eingegriffen hat obwohl es gar
nicht rechtmäßig gewesen es ist ja am
anfang auch ist am anfang auch
nachvollziehbar wenn noch gar keine
daten vorliegen am anfang wir sind alles
menschen wir wussten alle gar nicht was
auf uns zukommt aber jetzt nach fast
zwei jahren liegen so viele daten noch
weltweit vor dass ich mir schon
gewünscht hätte dass wenigstens
wenigstens maßnahmen formuliert werden
bei denen ersichtlich ist okay wenn wir
also unter diesen voraussetzungen können
wir alles fallen lassen und ich diese
frage wann das geschieht wurde mir noch
niemand fordert aus der politik und die
ich kam diese
diskussions richtung ausreichend in der
öffentlichkeit vor nein kam sie nicht in
der korona krise wurde wurden diese
meinung vom kanzleramt gehört von der
bundesregierung gehört nein sie wurden
zu lange nicht gehört eigentlich bis
heute nicht gehört das einzige was mich
zuversichtlich stimmt ist am stammtisch
findet diese meinung sehr wohl stadt am
stammtisch gibt es genau diese
diskussionskultur unter freunden im
garten gibt es genau diese
diskussionskultur es gibt sie nur nicht
in der politischen blase da gibt es eine
einheits meinung beim thema corona wie
bei vielen anderen themen auch und es
gibt auch nicht in der parteipolitischen
debatte auch da war man sich zu lange
viel zu eigentlich beim thema corona wie
gesagt zuversichtlich stimmt mich dass
das am stammtisch nicht der fall ist da
gibt es eine tolle diskussionskultur
darf darf man einfach alles sagen was
man sagen möchte und da wird die meinung
und der streit genau wie hier in der
sendung noch offen ausgetragen darf man
schon aber ich erlebt dass die teilweise
anders vielleicht ist es auch
vielleicht ist es ein teil dass ein teil
meines problems ist ich mich in einer
gewissen blase oder so befinde aber ich
habe nicht das gefühl dass man also
staatlich gesehen wird die
meinungsfreiheit auf jeden fall
gewährleistet aber ich habe das gefühl
dass die bevölkerung dass der einzelne
mensch ich kann es nicht für alle
sprechen aber so erlebe ich dass das der
das gar nicht so lebt und auch gar nicht
so so fühlt und da gar nicht das
bedürfnis so groß ist und ich habe auch
das gefühl dass generell
freiheit auch gar nicht so diese ja eine
hochkonjunktur gerade hat sondern das
bedürfnis nach sicherheit und noch
jemanden also einem starken start der
sagt so und so hast du zu leben und bei
einigen menschen habe ich sogar eine
erleichterung gemerkt die fast
erleichtert waren was die diese diese
verantwortung abgenommen bekommen weil
ihnen jemand gesagt okay du machst genau
nach dieser anleitung lebst du jetzt
dein leben und und wenn wo andere dabei
erwischt sie das nicht einhalten haben
sich schön aufgestellt und gesagt du du
willst ein schlechter mensch weil du
dich dran hält aber zurück zu dem thema
ich erlebe das anders in meinem
bekanntenkreis beim zum beispiel mir
auch teilweise schon vorgeworfen wurde
weil ich corona politik auch viel
thematisiert habe dass das ja im grunde
ich ja verantwortlich wäre wenn leute
sterben aber was ist das bitte schön
argument also man kann ja dieses
argument immer bringen dass man dieses
und jenes machen kann um menschenleben
zu retten aber dann könnte man genauso
argumentieren und sagen okay ab sofort
gibt es gar kein datenschutz mehr weil
wenn alle daten dieser welt offen legen
könnte man jeden mord verhindern wenn
jeder menschen drohne bekommt die die
einen film permanent auf schritt und
tritt verfolgt das allen behörden allen
menschen zugänglich ist und wenn man mit
menschenleben argumentiert wenn man die
büchse der pandora öffnen erst mal über
diesen frame öffnet frage ich mich ob es
nicht der ansonsten irgendwas größerem
ist das dass wir jetzt auch teilweise
über grippe gesprochen dass wir jetzt
anfangen auch zu überlegen ob wir die
massen pflicht einfach zu immer
beibehalten weil man könnte andere neues
guten grippewelle und wir haben es heute
gehört vom lka chef der schon versucht
hat die grippe auf eine stufe erhöht
corona zu stellen ganz klar warum
eigentlich nicht das ist nachher eine
logische konsequenz vielleicht gibt es
irgendwann auch den grippe lockdown kann
weil man sagt ja grippe ist ja auch
gefährlich und dann hat man sich an die
maske gewöhnt und kommt im flugzeug und
dann hat man die maske weiter auf
absolut richtig aber die frage ist ja
auch wie kommen wir eigentlich in so
eine welt wo man den eindruck hat so wie
sie es beschreiben auch das eigentlich
immer stärker meinungen vielleicht gar
nicht mehr gefühl zumindest von vielen
bundesbürgern aber auch in anderen
ländern hat man ja umfragen gar nicht
mehr so gesagt werden können ich
erinnere ein fall der sich in der spd
zugetragen im märz dieses jahres als
wolfgang thierse
einfach mal gesagt hat er lässt sich
nicht vorschreiben wie er zu sprechen
hat und da ging es um diese frage gender
stern und das einbeziehen von
minderheiten in das in den ganz normalen
sprachfluss also am besten den
doppelpunkt unter sternchen mitsprechen
und dagegen hat er sich geweigert und
dann gab es sofort von der
parteivorsitzenden es gehen und den
parteivize kühnert ein workshop gab
massiv kritik an
wolfgang thierse der nun wirklich also
auch eine eine beeindruckende vita hat
zweithöchster mann im staat war als
bundestagspräsident so und es gipfelte
darin dass wolfgang thierse am ende
saskia esken fragte seine
parteivorsitzende nach dem motto willst
du mich eigentlich noch in der spd haben
oder ist das was ich hier sage und
möglicherweise ganz vielen menschen aus
dem herzen sprechen ist das vielleicht
gar nicht mehr möglich so was in einer
partei wie der spd zu sagen und daran
erkennt man ja auch wie eingeengt der
meinungs- korridoren uhr wird da diese
schienen geradezu meiner argumentation
ganz kurz zurück wird am stammtisch
geändert oder nicht ich behaupte an
keinem deutsche stammtische gehindert
das heißt das ist die meinungs- hoffnung
in deutschland die liegt genau da also
ich sitze nicht nicht am stammtisch
kelten ich stehe meistens an der bar
wird auch nicht geändert und es ist
blödsinn mit dieser spende reich kann
respektvoll mit schwulen und sonstigen
umgehen und mit allen konsorten die
unterwegs sind und dieser blödsinn damit
mitarbeiter mitarbeiterinnen und das
immer so darzustellen davon wird nichts
besser
intern ist auch ein thema das thema ist
hat man darüber sprechen kann dass man
in die eine oder andere ecke gestellt
wird und das habe sich in deutschland
viele themen sind so komplex noch das
gender thema ist sehr komplex da kann
man auch sehr viel darüber sprechen was
mich stört ist das egal auch
dass ich sagen kann in meiner generation
gerade in dieser akademie kabel dass es
da kein keinen diskurs überhaupt
stattfindet an meiner uni ich habe
kommunikationswissenschaften studiert da
hieß es dann irgendwann von einem
dozenten alle die nicht ländern in ihrem
haus arbeiten gibt es nämlich nicht
anders verweigere ich diese annahme und
es ist ja grammatikalisch es ist ja kein
fehler sagt ein formfehler aber da
findet ja da wird an das quasi ein
bisschen ja aufgezwungen
[Musik]